the Joe Rogan experience what are these
people do for a living a lot of the is
livestock so they raised their their yak
dairy you know meats that they'll
transport over to the capital city but
they're just out there living the purest
way of life I remember walking through a
part of montgó direction I went over
eight days without seeing a single
person for eight days so what have you
want to know what the world was like I
don't know million two million years ago
homegirl you is the place that you'll
get to experience a bit of that you know
just wilderness just out there did you
encounter any wolves or anything they're
wolves they were the bigger wolves as
well they were gray wolves
I didn't luckily so footprints but you
can see whether that was wild dogs or
wolves I had a wild dog approached my
tent like 2:00 3:00 in the morning I
just hid heavy breathing and footsteps
outside my tent I'm in the middle of the
Gobi Desert alone hunting a human in
days and I'm there in the middle of a
tent a knife and 100 torch and the other
shake in a journey thinking this is a
person outside I'm showering and they're
not replying unzipped it's like a wild
dog it was fine wasn't aggressive
aggressive but yeah it was just so I
remember my logistics manager my
ulaanbataar based my Mongolia based
logistics manager said to him can you
imagine no quiet how silent it's gonna
be in the Gobi Desert and he replied he
just said there's no such thing as
silence do you mean there's no such
thing as silence they have like silence
rooms you know torture panic room
silence from with the headphones and
whatnot it was like I'm not gonna tell
you you know you'll get out there and if
you've hit the right spots of the Gobi
Desert you'll know what I mean and I did
I remember I was just again in the
middle of the Gobi Desert hadn't seen
anyone days and there was no breeze
there was no flies there was no people
there was just no noise pollution
whatsoever and I was just looking around
I could just hear this faint noise
almost like a a high-pitched humming
noise very faint though and I thought it
could be like air leaking from my water
container it could be my trailer so I
walked a few hundred meters away from my
trailer and I could still hear it talk
with five to ten minutes to figure it
out that I was like and as such the
point of silence now it's so quiet I can
hear my own body functioning and that's
what he meant
there's no
such thing as silence because when
you're at the point of silence you can
finally hear your own body ticking over
never hit it before never hear that
since look what are you hearing just the
faintest humming noise almost like it's
almost like coming from the inside but
you can't not not hear it as long as
you're living as long as you breathing
you're hearing that noise oh when
everywhere I was just like yeah nothing
about it it's it's my body it's ticking
over
so how long you walk in through the Gobi
Desert here in your body
oh no you when you're walking you can't
really hit when you stop yeah yeah and
it's got to be no wind a lot of the time
it's very breezy those storms you know
you see you're essentially walking
through a dead area right it's lifeless
yeah how much water you have on you when
you're doing this with that so my
container was 20 litres 20 kilograms but
it was never always full that's a lot of
weight that's a lot of weight yeah plus
you have all the other stuff yeah that's
why you have mounted really I think the
trail on its own 40 kilograms don't know
what does a pound 60 70 pounds maybe and
an empty load cuz it was mild steel
built in my family friends by garden you
know really
yeah just puncture-proof tires full
rubber so it was heavy but it was robust
and then the water container at 20
litres 20 kilograms needed at a maximum
Lord yeah so when I was to her
effectively I went through the water
when I was really suffering with the
dehydration so at that point the trailer
was a lot lighter it was under 100
kilograms at that point but I'm low on
water you know right I've sort of ration
in the last remaining durables up to
where I make it to the community so on
maximum load a hundred twenty kilograms
water was the biggest issue and always
was the biggest issue that's when the
previous guy was was evacuated on three
three occasions which terrified me as
Rose that Navy soldier desert explorer I
was just a scuba diver boy-toy living in
on a beach in Thailand you know so I did
have my worries I did stop planning
Mongolia as well because of that start
to doubt myself at the same time I
realized you know just because no one's
found a way to do something it doesn't
mean it can't be done
what made you feel like Mongolia was the
wildest place probably because it was
really close I
I'm living inside on my initial my
initial idea is get a cheap bike $10
cycle to Mongolia
cyclocross Mongolian walk back the other
way or cycle to the stop went in the
east and then walk to the west and I
thought if I did that would have died I
wouldn't have made it I was lack of
preparation so that's why I went back
home back to the UK for the right
preparation the right training and again
as I say now it's not like Vietnam the
cycle when it was all very reckless he
was all meticulous planning detailed
planning and Mongolia for me just
drugged me it's that I was on the travel
route for two years at this point and I
come across people what they say they
plan to go here next I plan to go there
next what they've come from Cambodia
Vietnam but no one had ever said
Mongolia really Sasha's fascinating at
home to be outside mountains the Gobi
does it you've got a reindeer tribal
community up north you've got the Eagle
hunters in the West he camels down south
of the Gobi there's just like these
countries fascinating and from that
point on I was just like I wonder maybe
100 miles let's walk maybe 200 as I heck
why not go for the length when I start
to look for people who'd done it before
it wasn't for any record it's just for
the fascination that's when I realized I
can find any evidence to suggest that
anyone had completed the sole on a
support walk but I did find the guy who
previously attempted and he was a nice
guy he responded I asked him what the
dangers are paid less the the gray
wolves that come on nomadic drift is
this stagnant Ragna well afters they can
sometimes be a problem yeah
drawing on their holes they'll roam and
they're big that big Mongolians
wrestling's their sport
so that's stocky it's in the history as
well as in it with chingus Chinggis Khan
Younis Khan as we know it yeah you know
but the LA can they could be bigger than
issue and he just sent this huge list I
was like yeah maybe I'll look for a
different countries maybe I'll walk
across a European country or something
[Applause]